hey everyone welcome back
thanks for coming uh we're switching
gears from convex programs to
uh complexity of counting and maybe also
other things um so welcome to andrea
she's a andrea andrea i'm actually not
sure andre andrea okay thanks um she's a
postdoc here at berkeley uh
take it away
hello everyone um so i'm gonna talk to
you about fine grain worst case to
average case reductions um
you know this uh
useless acronym
um
and
this talk is going to
rely heavily on some results from
this paper new techniques for proving
fine grain average case hardness
with mina and virginia
but before that i'm going to
introduce very briefly fine grain
complexity and some fun
simple average case worst-case average
case reductions so first what is fine
grain complexity
so it's an area of complexity where
we're really concerned about the
constants in the exponent so this is
like n squared versus n to the 2
minus epsilon so n to the 1.99
and an example of a hypothesis which i
won't define yet but
if you've heard of it is the three-sum
hypothesis that falls in this category
but we're also concerned about
exponential differences
um the strong exponential time
hypothesis also called seth is about the
k-sap problem and it's concerned about 2
to the n versus 2 to the 1 minus epsilon
times n so once again this sort of
concern about what exact constant is
happening in the exponent
and our goal here today uh is we'd like
to understand how hard our favorite
problems are on average and what we
really mean by that is it would be nice
to know explicit distributions on which
we believe these problems are hard um
and we're going to use reductions as a
technique to understand what
distributions some of our favorite
problems are hard under
so what does this look like in general
you've got some worst case problem p
and we want to show that p is equivalent
to potentially many different calls to
some average case problem q and this
average case problem q is going to be
drawn from some particular distribution
uh
and
the success probability of an algorithm
solving q is over both the randomness of
that algorithm the coin slipping but
also the randomness of the distribution
and so the you know crucial thing to
remember here is if you have an average
case algorithm with success probability
one minus epsilon it's allowed to be
wrong consistently on an epsilon
fraction of the inputs
so there's no
way to sort of naively boost yourself
out of this situation if you shove in
the same input that it was wrong on it's
allowed to be wrong on that input over
and over again in the same consistent
way
and i just want to note that this is
different than randomized algorithms
where if epsilon is you know less than
half you can sort of boost a naive way
of just plugging the same input over and
over again and then taking the majority
so now we've discussed that i want to
talk about a really fun example of a
worst case average case reduction this
comes from a paper of bloom libyan
rubenfeld
and so here's the question
how hard is matrix multiplication on
average
so
first let's start with worst-case matrix
multiplication we've got some a and b
they're n by n matrices and we're going
to say that we're over some prime field
fq
so what's the you know average case
problem
uh it's going to be the
problem of getting uniformly random
matrices over this field f q
and what we're going to do to produce
our average case problems that will
solve our worst case problem is sample
two random matrices x and y from fq
and our problems are going to be of the
form
a plus x
times b plus y
x times b plus y
a plus x times y and x times y
so a couple of things to note each of
these matrices in each of these
individual problems
looks uniformly random we've you know
added onto an entry a totally random
field element and so it looks
just like an iid random matrix
there are of course correlations between
these different matrices uh if you were
to take the first and last for example
you would totally determine the worst
case matrices you plugged in but each
instance by itself looks totally random
and you know what happens here well we
can do some sort of classic
inclusion exclusion
we take the first subtract the two
second problems and add the third add
the fourth and you get back exactly the
matrix you wanted
and so you know
what i want you to get from this fun
example is both that average case
reductions are super fun and you should
do them
the other thing i want you to get is
that we're making a bunch of correlated
calls
each call is indistinguishable from the
uniform distribution or whatever
distribution we care about
or potentially it'll have a small total
variation distance
and then as long as you have a
relatively low error you can union bound
across these various instances in order
to show that you can solve your problem
with high probability
this is a fun example
now i'm going to talk a little bit more
about some recent results and work in
this area
so the highlighted results for the rest
of the talk are going to be a framework
that allows you to give
average case hardness for worst case
problems as long as that problem is
described by what we call a good low
degree polynomial
i will also very briefly mention a new
type of problem we described called a
factored problem
where it turns out that the counting
version of these factored problems have
good low degree polynomials and so you
can get nice worst case to average case
reductions
in the process of getting here
um i want to tell you a bit of a story
and that story is about how you go from
this paper of volatile in 2017 to blonde
assarad all 2019 to our paper
and this paper is going to focus a lot
on the cake leak problem
but especially in order to explain some
of this ball at all work
i'm going to define some of the problems
of fine-grained complexity that we care
about
so what are the core problems of
fine-grained complexity
um there is seth
which is the hypothesis that k-stat
requires 2 to the n times 1 minus little
of one time so this is exactly what i
mentioned before you know here we're
having a strong opinion about the
constant in the exponent
and our case that problem you know you
forget you're given a boolean formula
it's in conjunctive normal form each
clause is of size k
we also have the three sum problem
you're given a list of n numbers you can
think of these numbers as being between
negative n cubed and n cubed if uh that
sort of
makes it easier to sort of internalize
and the hypothesis is that it requires n
squared
minus little o of one time
once again a strong opinion about the
exponent
and finally we have the all-pair
shortest paths problem you're given a
graph with n nodes and weighted edges we
want to know the shortest path distance
between all pairs of nodes in this graph
and the hypothesis is that this requires
n cubed minus the low of one time
for all of these problems we have
algorithms that achieve
uh you know two to the n times one
uh
you know two to the end time for sure
um and for these other problems
similarly we have algorithms that run in
you know n squared minus some function
that's a little low of one and n cubed
minus some function that's a little of
one
great so i'm going to
tell you about some more fun problems
and reductions um
so first is the orthogonal vectors
problem you're given a list of n01
vectors and i want you to tell me if
there's a pair of these vectors that
have a dot product of zero and the
hypothesis is that this requires you
know n squared time
and the fun fact is that this is implied
by seth
next we have the zero k cleak problem
you're given a dense graph with weighted
edges and we want to return true if
there's a k click whose edge is sum to
zero
and the hypothesis is that this requires
n to the k time note this is like brute
force right you just like you're trying
you're looking at every single click
and the fun fact is that for the three
version of this so the zero three click
hypothesis so about triangles it's
implied both by threesome and by apsp
so you know this is sort of the world of
fine grain complexity there's all these
problems a lot of them sort of brute
force time and many of these hypotheses
are implied by
the core hypotheses of the area
so in comes uh baladal brsv17
and their goal is they want to give a
worse case to average case reduction
from some of these really fun
fine-grained problems that we care about
and they totally succeed
um they're able to start from this
orthogonal vectors problems that i
described uh in fact even the counting
version so more plausibly hard right
like you know it's not just that you
need to tell me if there is or isn't but
like in fact how many you have so that
that's can only be harder
and they're able to show that if this
counting version of orthogonal vectors
is hard then computing uh this function
fov is hard
and they're also able to show for the
zero kick leak problem that i mentioned
that computing uh this function f zero k
peak is hard are we supposed to know
what the functions are no i'm about to
describe discuss that yeah so
what what the heck are these functions
so these functions are just polynomials
of our finite fields
that happen to on zero one inputs
have the exact same output as the
relevant problem
and
you know there's some polynomial over a
finite field
uh and what they're able to show in
ball at all
using you know previous work
is you know if you have any problem p
and you want to generate a polynomial f
p such that uh it has low degree and you
can compute your worst case input
uh your worst case you know function uh
orthogonal vectors for example
from
a call to you know fov
then this problem is hard on average and
in fact you know hard on the uniform
distribution over this field size um
this field of size queue
so you know they get an average case uh
hardness from the worst case
the problem with this is uh
why do we care about this particular
function
yes
uh actually
so when you define the orthogonal
vectors problem
is a conjecture that gets hard over
every field over some field
so uh this is hard when uh
i think this is normally framed as being
over the integers
uh
certainly any field of size larger than
uh log n
you're going to be fine we're like if
it's like omega log n field size uh
it'll be the same because it turns out
the instances where we can show it's
hard from seth
are ones where the like length of the
vectors in the first place is that short
um
probably you can get away with
some you know field sizes other than
that um but yeah this is normally
thought of as yeah
um
right so
these have a nice correspondence to the
worst case problems we cared about um
over zero one but over this larger field
size they no longer have a meaningful
correspondence and so there's there's
cool things that they're able to do um
with these polynomials they're able to
make proofs of work for example
um
however
it'd be really nice to understand
whatever problem we cared about so it'd
be nice to get back to zero one
um and it turns out that there's you
know
further work that was able to get back
to zero one with cake leak
so i just want to like walk through
what the result is and then i'll
describe
you know some perspective on how that
result was achieved so
you have some problem worst case
counting cake leaks so we're given a
graph
every edge either exists or doesn't and
the question is you know are there k
nodes such that all k choose two edges
exist
and it turns out you can you know turn
this into some polynomial f clique
and then you can use
some sort of you know standard
techniques in order to show that
computing this polynomial is hard over a
relatively large field a field of size
about log n
and then it turns out you can take that
and go back to counting cake leaks over
error shrinking graphs
and this you know happened across a
series of works ending in boat asara
2019
so let me start by
defining what this polynomial is for
clique
so for f clique
the what we do is we sum across all
uh monomials they're going to correspond
to every possible choice of k vertices
in the graph
and the monomials are formed by
multiplying all of the k choose two
edges
or the variables corresponding to the k2
two edges
within that clique
so
this value is going to be zero for a
given set of you know vertices if it's a
clique and it's going to be a one if
it's not so this is great
um
and
it's not the other way you want to be
one if it's if i want to count please
don't want one if it's a i'm sorry
you're totally right i flipped that it's
a one if the clique exists and it's a
zero if it doesn't if some edge is
missing then that edge is zero and it
causes the whole thing to be zero
so the nice thing here is this is
relatively low degree when k is small
right so like think of k equals three
the degree here is three right like this
is a nice low degree we've been talking
a lot about wanting low degree things
um so now there's this step where it
turns out you know if you have some
uh polynomial
over finite field you can show that the
average case calls to this polynomial
finite field are also going to be hard
so here uh it turns out for various
reasons we're going to need uh the
finite field to be of size roughly log n
and so you can think of this as
evaluating this polynomial when every
single edge has some random value
between zero and log n
and if you you know sort of prefer to
think about this as a graph problem you
can even think about this as putting
weights on all the edges between zero
and log n
and now the weight is actually
corresponding to a multi-edged version
of this problem and we're counting the
number of cliques
in this multi-edged version
so this is a low and good but this does
not look like a k-click problem over an
error-running graph
and
uh builder like rothbloom go from here
and sort of come up with a gadgety way
to get back to
a catholic problem that's unweighted but
it doesn't look like aerodynamic graphs
instead wanda sorry at all sort of take
this version of the problem where you
have weights on all your edges
and they try and get back to zero one
and they do this basically
we have you know many of the authors
here so they can tell me if i'm
misrepresenting them
uh but by breaking these down as bitwise
multiplications
so you know we have this example here of
this particular triangle with weights on
it
and we can of course instead think of
this as a bunch of different instances
of a cake leaf problem
eat in particular corresponding to every
possible bit multiplication so we can
multiply the higher order bits by
looking at the question of whether or
not there's a clique in the graph of one
one zero
we can multiply
two higher bits in one lord or a bit
with the four instances formed by every
possible choice of
you know two higher order bits and one
low order bit
we can check the three instances of
two low order bits and one higher order
bit by every possible combination
they're in and finally uh the low order
bits
and you know indeed this is going to
multiply out to the correct value
uh you know it turns out that 3 times 2
times 1 is equal to 4 plus 2.
you know what does this look like in
general
well if i have some graph
and i've got a set of edges a and a set
of edges b and a set of edges c
this f clique polynomial is equivalent
to multiplying across all the possible
choices of cliques
the various uh edge values corresponding
to that clique
and if you imagine creating
one instance for every possible choice
of grabbing an ice bit of all the
weights in a adjacent bit of all the
weights in b a case bit of all the
weights in c and then waiting
appropriately by this 2 to the i plus j
plus k you now have a bunch of instances
and they're all zero one instances
of cliques right you know this is now
just a cake leak problem we're just
counting cliques over you know zero one
graphs
so you know in some sense we're done um
and there there is something misleading
i've done which is uh you know r bits of
you know random values between zero and
log n
uh iid zero one and the answer is
they're not quite uh but bub19
basically expand the size of their
numbers into a larger
uh field
and then it turns out those bits are in
fact
uh have very small total variation
distance away from zero one
id i got lost with a k-part thing so
what why did
no you're starting with hardness now of
counting
tweaks in k-power type graphs
yeah it's it'll sort of be easiest it
turns out you can go from
non-k-part-type version to a k-part-type
version and then it's sort of easiest to
go from the keyboard
like you're still having one argument to
go between the k-parts i think and and
not
so so but the the thing is there's a
difference this is the inclusion
explosion that we saw like you said we
saw a like a
few high order like two higher order in
one low order
or something else but but this
polynomial is a different polynomial
once you have apartheid and this
polynomial has very nice properties it's
just like it's good expansions okay
to sort of self-reduce law
yes what is the fraction of graphs that
you need to solve the average-based
problem
that's a great question so if you have
numbers that have like l bits and you
have degree d here
then you're going to have l to the d
instances and we're going to need
success probabilities because we're
going to union bound across all of these
instances
that go as one minus you know like
whatever
one-third times uh you know
oh it only depends on uh
so it depends on k in the exponent and
log n ends up showing up uh in the base
of that so it ends up being something
like log n to the k squared basically
um instances that we're generating
or really uh wandasara at all or
generating
um
yeah so the the k-partiteness is coming
in here because we want to be able to
say that we're grabbing like the ice bit
of a weight in a and the j-spit of a
weight in b and if we were like
totally mixing the graph it wouldn't be
meaningful to say that the i-bit of a
weight in a
because you know
uh
we'd have potentially cliques that are
all
aaa edges so this k-part tightness
allows us to do
um
this sort of splitting
and then it turns out to get you know
two general graphs and from general
graphs you can do including exclusion
arguments
to get around the fact that like you
sort of have these stray edges
that exist everywhere that's not in a
k-part type graph
so you know
they're able to start from a worst case
counting cake league problem and show
that counting cake leaks over error
training graphs is just as hard
and
it wasn't really about being in zero one
at the end and it wasn't really about uh
sorry it was about being in zero one at
the end it wasn't really about the cake
league problem
so what was it about
um it was about the fact that f was a
sum of monomials that were all of degree
exactly d
it was about the fact that it was
departed in this way so that we can say
that like we're grabbing the ice bit of
all the a type things and the you know j
bit of all the b type
variables
we knew that d was not too big you know
as your excellent question asked we have
this overhead that's exponential in the
degree of this polynomial
and additionally we needed the output of
f and p were the same
we can sort of make this a little bit
more formal by saying
that a good low degree polynomial will
have a degree that's quite small so log
n over log log n
this is
the degree needed in order to make the
overheads in this uh algorithm
sub-polynomial so it'll be n to the low
one and then find grain complexity we
sort of ignore this
um
it needs to be strongly departed we
define strongly departite as being a
function that has
monomials all of size exactly d where
every like monomial is formed by
grabbing exactly one variable from each
partition of variables
and finally we need that this polynomial
fp and the problem p run on the same
zero one input produce exactly the same
output
and what do you get if you have all
these properties
so if p has a good low degree polynomial
you can think of this as being like if
you sort of announce that p in fact
roughly is a low degree polynomial right
over 0 1
then
if worst case p requires t of n time the
average case version of p requires t of
n to the log n
to the d time uh
as long as an algorithm succeeds with
probability one minus one over log n to
the d
and if you want to like not have these
you know values of d floating around
given our constraint on d we can say
that
any average case algorithm that succeeds
with a probability that's like 1 minus 1
over a polynomial regardless of how
small that polynomial is implies that
the average case algorithm's running
time will be the same as the you know
worst case algorithms running time up to
a subpolynomial factor
and if you don't want to think about
probabilities d you can think about you
know this
you know very small polynomial
probability as being the probability
throughout the rest of the talk
so you know what's what's going on at a
high level here
we go from a worst case problem p
to some average case problem fp
and we go from this average case problem
sp
to
the uniform average case of p
by sort of doing these bit
multiplication tricks
so i have gone way faster
than i did in my practice versions
and i have already reached the end of
this talk
um so
i can either conclude and then take 30
minutes of questions
or
i have another set of slides about uh
i have another set of slides about this
same talk area that will take about 30
minutes
what do people prefer
why don't we at least pause for for
questions that can be broad-ranging to
see if there's some
what we have
are there interesting cases of worse to
average case productions where
the
queries
are uncorrelated or of some degree of
k-wise independence
so that then the success probability can
be
a little bit better than you would get
from the union band
yeah so in this uh volatile 2017 paper
um
they
so they have their various polynomials
um like fov for example
and
when they evaluated on some input i zero
the way they end up showing that this
polynomial is hard on average um they're
going to be able to show a two-thirds
success probability on average implies a
faster you know worst-case algorithm
and the way they're doing this
is they define some new
polynomial g
which is just equal to
fov
of i naught plus y times a random input
plus y squared times some other random
input so each of these inputs that are
capitalized here are you know n bit
uh sorry n
uh
are you know from f q
to the n
and these are you know
y here is like some single value from
the field of q
and so g is now a univariate polynomial
and if fov had degree d
then g has degree 2d
and now what they do with g is they note
that
basically that you can do polynomial
interpolation that if you're getting two
thirds of your point actually on this
polynomial and one third of your points
off this polynomial that you can
take all those data points and return
whatever
g of zero is
with high probability as long as you're
getting you know two-thirds good quality
points
and
g of zero as it turns out is exactly the
f of the i naught you wanted to compute
um so that's a nice case where it's it's
not as if all of your average areas have
to be correct exactly
um
but in a lot of the
a lot of these like reductions you
instead like spit out this large number
of instances
and have no
real way to error correct that we know
of
but i do think that's like an
interesting direction to go in to try
and improve this probability
yes
mentioned something about uh
input in factored form
yes i know you use that as a basis it
was encrypted system or something if
yeah so uh
i can talk about um the factored
problems um and that's the sort of like
30 minutes of content uh
the basic idea is you can take uh these
various problems of like orthogonal
vectors for example
and instead of having every
vector just be a 0 1 vector of length n
you split it into
a sorry a 0 1 vector of length d
you split it into
various pieces each of size b
where you're actually allowing a set of
potential values of zero one vectors of
length b
and then
you sort of imagine that you're actually
sort of representing in a compressed
form all possible vectors formed by
selecting one element from each set
and so
we allow potentially two to the d
vectors to be represented if you sort of
densely filled in these sets
and
despite the fact that this is like way
more expressive than the original
orthogonal vectors problem it turns out
it has a much lower degree uh polynomial
representation and so we're able to do
these worst case to average case
reductions
for the factored version of orthogonal
vectors
um
but the problem now is like you have
this factored version that's very
expressive that we can show as hard on
average
but it doesn't mean that the orthogonal
vectors problem is hard on average
and in fact there's fast algorithms for
orthogonal vectors in zero one inputs uh
like in the uniform distribution where
you're selecting
every bit iid we have fast algorithms
so the worst case of this factored form
uh
is like tightly matches orthogonal
vectors so they're like
it's n squared like you know up to some
polynomial factors
and you can get lower bounds from
orthogonal vectors and that's from seth
um
so the worst case and average case of
this factored form match whereas the
worst case than average uniform average
case of orthogonal vectors don't match
and in this average case in fact four
can be used for some multiplications
let's say
that's not necessarily the same we're
interested in in the
final thing
yeah so
the the problem um
i'm being sort of fast and loose when
describing it verbally the problem is
all of these are counting problems that
we're showing hard and so
there's various ways to build like
fine-grained
we know how to build
various fine-grained proofs of work from
this but we don't know how to build
fine-grained public key exchanges or
anything like that
from
uh these worst-case average case
problems the fine grain key exchange
that exists
is instead based on
the decision version of
like the
uh
this like zero cake leak problem being
hard
and that decision version we don't know
how to show hardness from from the worst
case
so
30 minutes is going to put us pretty
behind schedule it's a big ask for you
to think on your feet do you want to
take 15 to 20 minutes is that a
possibility or do you want a break
if you want 15 minutes
go for it
i'm going to
give a brief conclusion of this
talk and then i will talk a little bit
more about factored problems and i will
be done in 15 minutes fantastic thank
you so much
sorry for speaking
literally twice as fast as in my
practice
uh so the results in this bring uh in
this paper you all have to re-learn what
it's like to talk to human faces instead
of just reading i think it's very
understandable
this is the results we covered uh were a
framework built on this paper of
bressler
wanda sarah and brennan
and we define this new type of problem
which i you know have mentioned but not
defined um call the factored problem and
we're able to show a bunch of reductions
from the various hypotheses i mentioned
all para shortest paths threesome seth
to a bunch of graph and string problems
uh
we also show that counting orthogonal
vectors is easy on average
and this is what i mentioned earlier so
it's what demonstrates the fact that we
shouldn't in fact expect an a good low
degree polynomial for orthogonal vectors
in some sense as an apology for
the fact that we you know construct
these factored problems um it's because
we don't
we shouldn't be able to construct
something like this for the problems we
sort of hope to
um
we also in that paper show a reduction
for accounting to detection on average
case zero cake leak
um and we show average case hardness for
counting any small sub graph
um
i also wanted to talk a little bit about
some papers that came out that i think
are cool
so uh that are very related to this uh
talk so hirohara and shimizu have a
paper on nearly optimal average case
complexity of counting by tweaks under
set
um
and they exactly sort of work on trying
to improve these probabilities instead
of having probabilities that look like
one minus one over some very large
polylog
they get improved probabilities uh but
not quite over the uniform distribution
and they have various you know
interesting things that show up there
uh additionally oden goldreich um has
this paper on counting t please mod 2
which in fact is like reproducing a
result
from the brethren brennan
wandasara paper
um
but sort of with a different twist or
direction um but i thought it was sort
of
a fun
repetition as it turns out of a result
that it already existed in the original
paper
um
yeah so we just did questions so
uh let me talk a little bit about
factored problems give me a second
i don't really understand why is that a
bad outcome you're saying like ah too
bad there's an average piece
you know
this yeah worst case or something
and then you are able to come up with
another
that is a fair point it is a good
outcome um
i
i'm always rooting for problems to be
hard
but you know that's that's uh
that's that's not very nice of me or
something you know like uh
um
yeah i think
you make a good point um
it's great
great news everyone
[Laughter]
so just a reminder the orthogonal
vectors problem we're given
n vectors um they're zero one vectors
and we want to return true if two of
them dot product to zero
so here's the factored version instead
of having these nice you know
vectors we instead have
every vector represented by multiple
sets
each of which include vectors
of a particular length so here we have
you know two sets uh with vectors of
length three in general these are going
to be you know think of them as like
root n sets each with vectors of size uh
root log n
oh sorry root log n sets each of with
vectors of size root log n
and
uh
we define the notion of like what it
means to be counting vectors over this
basically as
imagine decompressing all these vectors
that is you know u here is in some sense
representing four vectors because it has
two vectors in its first set and two
vectors in its second which are
uh the combination of the first half
being grabbed from the first set and the
second half being grabbed from the
second half of the set
if you count how many orthogonal vectors
exist between all these different sets
um
when uncompressed we count that as the
like count of factored orthogonal
vectors
and it turns out you can do this a lot
more efficiently than i just described
instead of uncompressing things if you
want to compare u and v
you can simply go in and check whether
or not there exists pairs that are
orthogonal indeed there are like this
pair for example and this pair
and then
every possible choice of you know one of
these orthogonal pairs grabbed with
another orthogonal pair is in fact going
to be orthogonal itself and so you can
simply like count the number of
orthogonal pairs in each of these sets
and then multiply those numbers
but that's not the sorry is this all
happening mod 2 like that's not the only
way to get orthogonal pair factors right
because i could get something that's
even from from the first and also or odd
from the first and on from the second
then it would
uh
we're asking whether or not the dot
product is zero not over f2 but it's all
over all over the interest all over
yeah you said that earlier thanks yeah
no it's a great question like you know
this sounded like you can't have
negative numbers just like they could be
minus three from the first half and
it's all zero winning they're all zero
one inputs they're all zero one inputs
um yeah so the fact that we're like
restricted to this you know set of zero
one inputs which it turns out is like
hard from sat um conveniently for us
uh or un inconveniently for us
uh allows us to do this trick where
we're we're just saying like okay we
need like the first half to be zero and
the second half to be zero doesn't mean
that it's not good that on the worst
case it's hard
um
so
uh just wanted to confirm my
understanding what is the dimension of
the vectors produced from these sets
is it like six or two
uh
six okay here yeah
um
and you know we allow the this notion of
empty sets uh but they're sort of
trivial in this case
and
what we're going to do with them
is the following
we're going to take these sort of you
know uncompressed versions of these
vectors
and we're going to create a polynomial
um and this polynomial looks totally
heinous
uh
but
the key is like you know just to like
totally like not have to look at that
polynomial um
really what we're going to be able to do
is
have a single uh
degree come from
this entire group of bits so in some
sense the normal orthogonal vector's
polynomial is going to have
a degree that sort of corresponds to the
length of
its vector
instead here we're going to have a
degree that corresponds to the number of
these groups and in some sense what's
going on is that we're pre-computing
everything about
what's going on within these groups of b
bits within the polynomial and then
we're able to just multiply across these
pre-computed pieces
um that's like a very hand-wavy way to
describe what's going on but that is in
fact sort of the internals of what's
going on in this truly heinous
polynomial um
so what do we get out of the end of like
producing these these polynomials what
we get is that
the average case version of this problem
is hard
yes
so i i was trying to brush over this
because these polynomials are like a lot
so what this is trying to do is across
all possible vectors
across all the groups so there's g
groups we're going to take the strings
represented in those groups and we're
going to check if they're equal to 0.
we're going to say there's a 1 if
they're equal to 0 and a 0 if they're
not so this is just like trying to be
the truth value like the boolean
yeah
and in a sort of more normal case would
be something like root log n
and
the polynomial that corresponds is
exactly a sum over multiplications over
sums where each sum
is
effectively pre-computing what these b
bit multiplications are
we are only including a pair of
variables that correspond to whether or
not the use vector contains the string
s1 so like the string a correspondingly
um in its iph set
if uh
we only include this multiplication of
these two if it turns out they already
dot product to zero and so by sort of
doing this pre-compute across all
possible b bit strings we've saved
ourselves this factor of b
in the degree
and in exchange we're sort of paying the
cost by having this really like
complicated by comparison
problem that we're able to show average
case hard
what we get out of all this in the end
is that this factored problem is hard on
average from seth
and these factored problems still have a
lot of that same combinatorial structure
that we use in orthogonal vectors
and we're able to get various graph and
string problems hard we're able to show
reductions to show that those various
graphs and string problems are hard from
this factored orthogonal vectors problem
using basically the same techniques we
use to show hardness for
regular orthogonal vectors
and i think that's enough of a sort of
very
brief discussion of
factored problems
so i will
end this and let the next person come up
and hopefully they won't speak
twice as fast
as they did in their practices
[Applause]
so we're switching over to zoom i think
um but further questions for andre while
we
do that
we had a time discussion oh yeah
so when you say you pre-compute
for those errors whether they are
i guess here is over the integers with
nothing negative it's the same as being
pairwise disjoint and then
when you say we pre-compute that you
mean you use
a fancier set of variables that
represent those
inner products of blocks
and then
the polynomial you constructed was a
polynomial of those
variables is that did i parse that right
basically so uh
the new variables are
representing sort of blocks of bits and
each monomial is only formed across
multiplying several different blocks of
bits if it happens to be the case that
those blocks of bits
uh
all like represent uh
bits such that their dot product is zero
so we're sort of
doing the pre-computation across which
monomials we happen to include or not
include
into uh
our multiplication and separating it
into those blocks creates that
multi-part tightness that you wanted for
your strong
your strong weight
yeah the strongly departed setup yeah
thank you
okay let's take andrea once more
[Applause]
and now